tout d'abord, je veux dire merci,
nous avons regardé des interviews et il
semble que vous ayez peut-être sauvé
la vie de ma fille qui était principalement Holly
sa fille juste de la génétique voudriez-vous
une menthe euh ouais j'ai besoin de votre aide mais
je veux savoir  si je peux vous faire confiance, j'ai en
quelque sorte l'idée que vous savez que
vous n'avez peut-être pas beaucoup de choix, eh bien, ma
situation est très délicate, c'est
là que je vous connais depuis la télévision,
vous poursuivez cette entreprise automobile pour
le procès  le
convertisseur catalytique oui c'est la moitié de ma journée l'
autre moitié je tourne sur la pornographie
quel genre comme quels films quel est votre
préféré non non tante tante porno
comme un croisé devrais-je écrire
ça ouais écris-le la foule de Vegas
essaie de répandre son  opération porno à
Hollywood Boulevard et je fais
tout ce que je peux pour l'arrêter merci le
porno est mauvais